Hi in video voting problems "I'm after the mark" as I explained CGP Gray
The ruling family is a problem, but this is not any ruling family, it is black
Rulers of the jungle since ancient times
There are demonstrations on the absolute monarchy and the citizens of the animal kingdom
They want to have a say in their style of government.
Assad abandons his crown under pressure, and the king's position becomes an electoral post
To ensure a smooth transitional period (and because she is smarter than her husband) the Lioness Queen
Will retain the throne with the power to determine the rules of the election
Her kingdom.
And announced that every citizen gets only one vote and that the candidate obtained
The largest number of votes wins the crown.
This voting method claims "the first after the mark" often (and abbreviates the silly shortcut
Or winner takes everything.
This system is simple, fair and logical, is not it?
actually no
It is a very ugly idea.
Why?
To see the problems of the first after the mark we must see the events of the primary elections
In the animal kingdom.
It is an encouraging time in this flourishing democracy, and seven hopeful candidates are advancing
To represent their parties, each of them performs his best efforts in election campaigns, and citizens
To the polling stations and then count the votes and the results come as follows:
The turtle gets 9% of the vote
The monkey gets 18%
Gorillas get 19%
The owl gets 14%
The cheetah gets 20%
The tiger gets 15%
The snake gets 6%
According to the rules of the first after the mark, the leopard crowns a winner in the elections and governs
For the duration of his term
But with one look at the results and you will see the first problem with this system:
Minority rule. The vast majority of the citizens (80%) wanted another king, however
Al-Fahd won, in this election there were only 7 candidates, but if we assumed that there was
Twenty, it was possible for the Cheetah to get 5% of the votes and yet be elected
This problem of minority rule is only the beginning
The second problem in the first after the tag is that the passage of sufficient time will cause a presence
Inevitable and inevitable for a dual party system
Why?
To see, we will see what happens during several election cycles
After the cheetah spends its time in office, it is time to vote again in the new democracy
This time all the citizens of the animal kingdom remember the result of the previous time
This information changed their behavior, especially those who voted for the tortoise and snake
They must face the fact that their candidates do not attract the citizens and the two parties and have no chance.
To win.
Turtle voters are not happy under the rule of the cheetah and then decide to support the other candidate
The biggest chance to win is the gorilla.
And the voters of the snake want to vote for the tiger because the candidate has the most common denominators
With them, but they are afraid because the cheetah has launched a negative campaign against
Rivals.
Snake voters do not like the idea of ​​gorilla rule and therefore vote strategically for the leopard
The final result is as follows: The cheetah gets 26% of the vote and the gorilla gets 28%
Thereby crowning a king
After seeing the results and after the cost of the election campaigns decides both the snake and the slide
Withdraw from any future elections
The system, which began with seven political parties, now has five
We go directly to the next elections
Only five candidates remain for the second time. Voters remember the events of the last elections
In this election they vote the owl knowing that their candidate has no chance of winning. And they are
Voters and democracies and their ideological tendencies are not very much the rest of the animal kingdom
They do not like cheetah or gorilla
Both the gorillas and the cheetah are aware of this and therefore they are doing a negative campaign against each other to benefit from
The fears of the middlemen.
The voices of the owl voters are divided as most of them vote against the candidate they hate
Rather than vote for a candidate they love
After these elections, the Gorilla gets 33% of the vote while the Cheetah gets 34% and thus wins
As the tortoise and the snake do, the owl withdraws from the next election.
In the last elections, we will see that monkey and tiger voters are dissatisfied. They both love
The candidate they encourage, but they must give up. Monkey voters agree
With gorillas in some subjects but they do not like cheetah at all. Tiger voters agree with
The cheetah is in some places but they do not like gorillas at all
They are strategically abandoning their preferred candidate for fear of winning the candidate they disagree with
With the king's greatest degree
The final result is the cheetah 49% and the 51% gorilla declaring either property
The last candidates to get out of the elections are the monkey and the tiger and the animal kingdom ends
Bipartisan system
Because the owl candidates are centrist and can change their mind about future elections, the cheetah may win
Then the gorilla gets it again and the cheetah wins again, but the status quo is
The two parties are not changing
The status of the citizens of the animal kingdom has ended up adhering to this system not because they are Cassali voters
Or because this is really what they wanted, but because of the way they were prepared
The mathematics of this system.
It is imperative that with sufficient time, all the first systems after the mark cause a two-party system
But the views of the voters have not changed since the initial elections, only 50 voters wanted
One of the Gorilla and Cheetah parties as their first choice and three-fifths want
Other candidates as a first choice
The majority of candidates are not interested in the electoral process because they are
Because they feel that they have no way of having a meaning to express their true preference
And the situation just gets worse here. If citizens are divided into electoral areas
Before the election, they are subject to fraud in the electoral division (Gerrymandering)
Cheating in the electoral division is somewhat complicated, but imagine a group of ten houses each with one vote
Three voters Fahd, three Gorilla voters and four owl voters.
If the voters are divided into groups before the elections, whoever determines where to draw
The lines have a big impact on who wins the elections
For example, if three of the pharaohs are gathered together with two owls and the like
With gorilla candidates you can remove the owl from the elections even though the owl candidates
They have the largest minority and were supposed to win under the "first after the mark" fair
If the Gorilla and Al-Fahd parties govern the period of electoral division
They have a strong motivation to secure safe seats for themselves
But we will go deeper into the division of electoral areas later
Damn this, say, let's vote for a third party and change the regime!
This introduces us to the last and the most terrible problem in the first after the sign:
Impact spoiler
Imagine after many years of rule of gorillas and cheetahs.
The tiger decides to return to the race. It is thought that citizens have despaired of
The current situation is that he has a chance to win
He prepares an electoral office and gets a sudden amount of donations from gold and goes
The animal news network is going to debate with the main candidates
The night of the election comes, but unfortunately, the tiger gets only 15% of the votes, mostly voters
Cheetahs who are considered closer to him in the political arena. Gorillas win elections easily
And become king
The first after the mark in the worst form: the better the third party
Hurts his voters by ensuring the loss of the party to which he is most consistent
And win for the party they disagree with
And do not forget, the gorilla is not an idiot, he knows how things go from where you think some came
Gold donations?
And while this happens the Queen is not satisfied
It was watching the elections and seeing that the regime was not in the interest of its citizens
And I thought, how is the election system good?
You should be able to vote for the most wanted candidate without worrying.
As more choices in candidates are better.
The system should not be vulnerable to Gerrymandering
It must be open to new political parties
Fortunately, there are many electoral systems to choose from
The alternative sound, but we will have to discuss in detail later
Thank you very much for watching.